So now let's step back a little bit and look at pre-processing in general. So you've already figured out three pre-processing rules for SAT.
And what I would like you to think about now is, in general, if we think about pre-processing,
what are the requirements that we would have for a pre-processing algorithm?
And of course, since we're defining pre-processing, I write requirements here in brackets
because it has a somewhat subjective component. But here's the three choices:
So what would be kind of good requirements for pre-processing?
The first one is that it must run in polynomial time; the second one is that pre-processing should always speed up the running time,
which means it would speed up the worst-case running time. And the third one is that pre-processing should not affect the solution.
By this, I mean that pre-processing does not change if we get a yes or a no as a result.
If we have an optimization problem, it's the same. So if, for example, we're solving vertex cover
and we're finding a solution of size ten, then after pre-processing, of course,
we would also like that solution size to remain the same and not get a solution of 11 or 12.
So please check which of these three here would be very sensible requirements for pre-processing.